all right Fillmore slim Fillmore where'd
you grow up where you from originally
I lose Anna what's it with City bad
Rouge Ben Rouge and tell me about your
childhood you had both your parents when
you were kid oh when I was kid I come up
news Anna you know and uh both my pants
you know are they hard worker my daddy
worked on the train my mama worked at
the bank and uh Susannah you know come
up with just a little kid underneath and
enjoying life you know had to work you
know well yeah I was working like
waiting for these drugstores and liquor
stores so you have role models that kind
of led you down this path that your life
took oh yeah I got a lot romance all
over the world yeah you know I'm the
Godfather you know even the hip hop
people you know snoop HTR lamb yellow d
they all know me yeah you recognize as
the the guy thought oh this game
what uh what kinda I mean what age were
you when you first got started as a
pendant Oh
CPP was my thing music was nothing see I
started off going to be a entertainer
you know I was big stars on the stage
like BB King and all those type of
people you know Lloyd price and all them
so and all the women screaming in
Holland and thing so I didn't know about
no pimping so that's what I wanted to be
I let say well I'm gonna be on attaining
old I have all the women screaming and I
let me looking at me on stage that was
my goal but the people that was there
with my thing you know I didn't know how
they're gonna be no film man you know
sorry that happened then where I happen
to be traveling on the road playing news
live long Sanders on this tool and I was
stopping a little town called Midland
Texas
we stopped in this town called Midland
Texas we was making like about ten
dollars a night
yeah what year is this
oh we're you saying and uh it's in the
fifth and sixth twofold 55 your yiridi
old are you I'm 85 you're 85
yeah so at this time you know we were
the performance right and a redneck so
to this club it was a hotel and the name
of this club was called the white front
you know and it was right there in
Midland Texas
so as we planed playing the blues and
I'm playing piano you know and uh like I
say we making $10 a night and uh I
noticed this chick right head on sit up
you know and she keep going out coming
back when I'm coming back so I didn't
know what was going on so in about five
days I'm sitting on the piano and she
come up she say here I said what is this
so that's for you so I thought like a
big tip right and then so I put the
money in my pocket you know and our
dance she kept doing this right so the
fellows in advance I man that's a
prostitute and they say uh you know we
don't need to be associated with up with
her I said man I was thinking middle of
money every night I was there now we
make about $10 a night I'm gonna take
the money I said you know so we're just
about citizens about maybe about a week
and I looked up I had about oh man close
about $125 and that was a bankroll gonna
and 55 56
so we already go back to LA they told me
no of course I answer I said what'd you
do say I go to bed with men for money I
said well what is death she say uh they
pay me money I go to bed with him so I
still didn't know then she explained it
to me you know about what it was she was
selling sex okay so so me being green
you know not knowing what's going on out
I would do playing music singing the
blues so uh you got ready to go back to
LA you know see a little suitcase
see I want to go with you I said Wow
I think what you haven't gone since I
got no hoodlum
so the fellows in the band the mail I'm
surprised - we're gonna take her back to
LA you know of the man check this out
I'm getting $10 a night look at my
little bankroll did she go on with me as
a matter of fact it's my van so if y'all
don't want to go y'all kissed the bus so
I brought it back to Los Angeles right
Dylan Burlington central you know and uh
see that are written up about fast food
let's called Coney Island so we uh so
see they were showing me the girls where
guys here right there on the corner
yeah the big record store there same one
that rule Ramos was awake ain't called
Dolph over Hollywood
so I told what the girls were good she
went out there and she came back the
second night she came back she had
another girl with her I said well who
was that see that's our wife although I
say Merritt she said but in the game
she's with us so now I got two girls so
now I put this I'll Frank get out in I
put the guitar in the corner and all
they start calling me for jobs around
the LA and I told them that somebody is
praying my place I had two girls on the
corner so I was getting paid you know
what kind of girls black girls white
girls then you would have sex with the
girls huh you would have sex with the
girls well you can have too much sex
with the girls you know see good the
game is a mind thing you know and if you
know and if the girls go out in it
turned eight to think that Nick on me
anytime you know so you'd have that too
much sex and then if you had a girl
she'd have to be released six months
before you even been to being with where
drugs part of the part of the game back
there the drugs in the game but I was I
wasn't about drugs your girls would use
drugs sometimes but you weren't involved
huh your girls would use drugs sometimes
oh I wonder would using drugs you know
but uh it's not your thing you got away
from me yeah yeah
have you done prison time what have you
done prison time oh yeah yeah I did I
follow you on see Passport
I did five years yeah took even married
huh have you been married I've been
married three times they said three
strikes yeah it's hard to do this and be
married at the same time I would think
yeah and then you have kids oh yeah I
got 17 years
15 grand key is either nine ten twelve
great grandkids so what what is the
origin of pimping like what yeah they
say it's the oldest profession where
prostitution is the oldest and about
funding about what do you think the
origin of this pimping thing is what
well for me it was uh it was fascinated
you know fashion you know and you get
all this money every night you know
fresh money every night you know you
know and uh I thought that was the king
of sunset yes that did all mine downside
down in law since that's where I got all
my pains huh la now there's a story that
goes around LA but the first time you
came to LA I'll send my game yeah and
then the cops gave you a hard time
yeah oh yeah oh yeah they they arrested
all your girls yeah there's all my dear
what happened after that
no the story was when I first went to LA
the pill there's been to go my girls oh
there was not a cop okay
the story exchangers all my girls by me
being fresh down there you know and they
get into cars and it drove up to me on
Sunset I know who get that retro we
sitting there pioneers chicken okay you
drove up something it's a digital girl
laughing yeah they're my girl if they're
not normal I said oh give me your money
so they with me now so what did they say
well I guess you don't know so you gain
so you might we'll go on back to Frisco
you know I said now I'm going to
telephone I'm gonna tell the phone and I
called them troopers you know Sam and it
was turn out call the troopers the
and they came in I said y'all I told my
said what did you say Clara LAX run on
the machine and come down and represent
me I told well wha
and when a limousine came up and they
all stepped out so all the prisms all
the women I said he mind as if you kiss
them I leave town so that the girls that
they stole were your second stringers oh
yeah and the ones that you flew down or
your first string Oh troopers yeah so
how was the game changed since you were
doing it because if the game is changed
there's no respect you know we would
like gentlemen of leisure
you know we didn't beat out women you
know and make them go out there you know
that's false in prison you know my thing
was you know I meet a lady you know and
she won't you know it seems interested
in my proposition then we went with it
you know but no force not that you know
the women love me today
you know because and the people love me
today you know I'll go around the spoon
I talk to young young people in the
schools I go to churches that's all with
young people you know I've been to a
couple of colleges you know how many
young people and this what I explained
to him what we did in our day you know
nobody's having our full fans our
grandmothers and thing though we live in
the projects so we didn't I did that's
what we were about you know but now like
I tell the young people you got
computers the other black girls there's
no that's been doing on my time I went
out with an electric attack writer you
know I was owned by computers and I like
a bit so I was I tell them you got to
give up better opportunity than what we
had you know I don't condone then they
go into the game you know I got a
daughter graduate from USC you know I
got a song as a paramedic you know I got
another song going to Chico State so uh
we did what we had to do what's more
important to you
for money well money you know you know I
was drooling up with money you know I
was in the game so I love money but
what's so good about it
they liked about it I was able to fall
back on my music see when I got out
there life and like dream my life of me
that I was able to pick up my guitar and
play the blues you don't put a record
out there I got a record out there now
it's number five in the world you know
and then I got all kind of Wars you know
inducted in the Blues Hall of Fame BB
King you know no so I was successful in
the game I wanted to fit the trophies
that the guy caught in the game and in a
Hall of Fame and the music so that's why
my books a blues man Michael G Filmore
Slim I conquered the stage and the
street the personality trait helped you
most as a temp well personality well I
always been a ladies man you know always
was Chama you know I could join me in
anything you know if I can stop in the
cheek you know I'll tell you story
I will of their body Chinese Theater you
know I just came back and I've seen this
Caucasian later all dressed in white
walking down sunset okay ready by know
how do you build all right bye honey
and I'll stop the car went around its
little alley right there you know for
you to get to the Chinese Theater you
know so I came around just toast you
crawl that and I pull up a black dog I
say baby she then what other here's your
car this is your car yeah then what to
me cause it's all white red inside this
car came for you
and she was so fascinated I think it in
spin around he got in the car he
couldn't find out we won't talk I'm
gonna find out she was
Oh J realms tobacco King was his
granddaughter you know we talk you know
and you know trying that out you know
totally have a good day No
what do you think the core of the pimp
and prostitute relationship is do you
think the girls are looking for a boy a
man in their life a boyfriend a father
figure
well I think they call you guys daddy
some of the girls I had I think I would
like a father take her to him I would
say you know yeah I would say that
what's the craziest thing you've seen in
all your years of doing the crazy
dancing I've seen a pimp running a hole
down Samson down Sunset Boulevard and
the cops man
yes started over there we were cut and
it changed about we're down to almost a
called in child but but the city to the
Kali and what's the most important
lesson you learned in your life in my
life is though if you play you gonna pay
so it ain't always light at the end of
the tunnel so we were having fun fancy
clothes fancy jewelry pens the car but
you know at the end you're going it's
just safe you might get the wrong female
this is the law say it takes two you get
the wrong female and just one that they
scared you go they're gonna do in Vegas
like I said all them all them all all
them players I ain't put him in
penitentiary well see we stay doctor
penitential see I had good lawyers hey
Willa Brown no he was out speaker thank
you my lawyer kicked out of jail
mmm prison that's right so how many
girls did you have it at the peak I had
23 girl walking up and down Sunset all
the way from ho bot to Beverly Hills the
Beverly Hills Hotel 23 girls how much it
so how much money do you make
well it there is you know some come in
with him
you know 500 so that 250 when you add it
all up it was a lot of money yeah but I
want to say this year I wouldn't go with
a pimp or the gentleman I recall myself
gentleman of leisure and that's why the
women love me today when I walk down the
street they want to take a picture with
me I walk down the street by UC Berkeley
all the students came I wanted to take a
picture with me and the police rolled by
and looked at they eat your heart out
all right all right film Orson thank you
so much for talking with me all right
Dan thank you
you
and I won't say one more thing oh sure
that's here okay now me real the Royal
13 me divine brown and gangster Brown
and can I read it
we are raw bits of his church we are
rorty's okay